je vous souhaite une sous est souhaite à
chacun la bienvenue aux sièges des
républicains les conventions
s'enchaînent tendance à lire chaque
semaine donc je me répète mais c'est la
vérité c'est l'avant dernière de nos
journées ou demi journée de de réflexion
nous avons traitée de beaucoup de sujets
12 ou 13 est le 13e je crois ou 12e je
sais plus je fais pas la comptabilité
précise
en tout cas on a abordé beaucoup
beaucoup de sujets il ya des sujets
qu'on n'a pas abordé par manque de temps
ou difficultés de d'articuler les sujets
avec les uns avec les autres mais on a
balayé assez largement le spectre des
réformes qu'il faudra faire pour
redresser notre pays et puis nous
terminerons ce cycle de deux journées de
travail de convention nous terminerons
la semaine prochaine par une convention
sur les institutions façon très concrète
c'est pas un colloque sur l vème
république
c'est des propositions précises pour
essayer de rapprocher nos institutions
des citoyens et puis surtout pour rendre
efficace l'action du gouvernement à la
fois sur le plan national mais aussi que
l'ensemble de ses relais locaux et je
pense aux collectivités territoriales
j'imagine que ça fera débat depuis on
soumettra en phase ii d'écriture quand
même un tout petit peu de temps puisque
nous devons présenter monsieur le
président du conseil nationale luc
chatel nous devons présenter devant le
conseil national
le 2 juillet un projet d des
républicains ce projet il s'articulera
après avec le débat de la primaire
ranger des républicains les républicains
sont en ordre
la commission nationale d'investiture se
réunit aujourd'hui quasiment chaque
chaque jour pour désigner des candidats
dans deux circonscriptions pour qu'ils
aient le temps de se préparer
devant devant leurs concitoyens
et puis on passera à la phase moins de
septembre début septembre la phase
active
du débat des primaires ce débat
permettra encore d'affiner nos
propositions nos idées notre manière de
voir ce que peut devenir la france dans
les années qui viennent et les efforts
qu'il faut pouvoir réaliser pour la
redresser puis après on passera au
troisième temps troisième temps c'est
l'élection présidentielle elle-même
c'est la campagne présidentielle elle
même avec un candidat légitime issu des
primaires et et ce temps-là permettra
encore d'affiner de corriger de proposer
pour pour la france et puis et puis
j'espère qu'on sera élu avec une vraie
majorité et que on passera la quatrième
phase qui est celle de la mise en oeuvre
voilà donc il ya quelque chose de très
cohérents dans notre approche est le
projet des républicains c'est la
première pierre au fond à 7 à cet
édifice qui va maintenant débuter sur un
vrai débat d'abord au sein de la droite
puis après entre la droite notre
candidat et l'ensemble des autres
candidats alors nous parlons d'une un
sujet qui est pas un petit sujet qui est
des affaires internationales les
affaires étrangères les relations
extérieures de la france a pris beaucoup
de noms différents enfin bref notre
diplomatie
cette diplomatie elle est chahuté le
gouvernement de monsieur hollande a pas
été vraiment formidable dans le domaine
international mais comme il n'avait pas
été formidable
et comme il n'est pas formidable dans le
domaine national non plus et un
équilibre on peut pas dire qu'il ya un
manque de cohérence
on voit bien que les choix qui ont été
faits par laurent fabius et puis puis
par d'autre part héros il n'y a pas de
choix c'est inhérent à monsieur ayrault
on voit bien que on voit bien que ce
sont des choix qui à chaque fois non pas
été le moins qu'on puisse dire très très
heureux on va évoquer tout cela au
travers d'une description du monde de
plus en plus dangereux plus en plus
incertain qui est le nôtre
les menaces se précisent les menaces
sont diffuses les menaces ont absolument
partout on parlera de la déstabilisation
du moyen-orient on parlera aussi de
l'afrique qui est un point extrêmement
important pour sa démographie et aussi
pour
la taille de ceux de ce continent on
oublie souvent d'en parler donc on en
parlera
je l'espère avec beaucoup de beaucoup de
profondeur
et puis on passera à l'idée que yann
inquiétant leadership manque de
leadership sur le plan international il
ya une organisation internationale nous
occupons un siège permanent au conseil
de sécurité des nations unies que
doit-on en faire d'autres pays montant
en grandes puissances on pense
évidemment à la russie on pense
évidemment au brésil ou à ou à l'inde on
parlera de ces nouvelles puissances qui
qui s'installe et puis on parlera pour
terminer dans une autre table-ronde à la
parade une vision d'une voix de la
francophonie de tout ce que nous pouvons
proposer pour essayer de stabiliser ce
monde en tout cas la france ne peut pas
y avoir de redressement français s'il ya
pas une politique solide et stable dans
le domaine des relations internationales
on n'est pas comme ça hors sol on est
sur la planète
on essaie de défendre cette planète sur
le plan de l'environnement il faut la
défendre sur le plan de la démographie
il faut la défendre sur le plan de la
géo stratégie les relations avec les
autres
qu'elles soient économiques
diplomatiques ou militaires sont des
relations qui impactent directement
l'état de notre de notre pays jean luc
chatel va introduire cette table ronde
pierre lellouche l'a activement préparée
qui notre délégué qui est député bien
sûr mais qui aussi notre délégué général
aux affaires internationales avec
beaucoup d'autres je salue alain
joyandet pour la partie africaine des
des choses et puis beaucoup d'autres qui
viendront se succéder à cette tribune
comme d'habitude nicolas sarkozy
conclura ses travaux vers midi c'est à
dire entre 11h58 et 12h02 pour être
précis je cède la parole immédiatement à
luc chatel